fui pra Irlanda cara aprender inglês na
Irlanda meu Deus do céu a pessoa fala
não é só ter paciência é bem facinho é
bem facinho Por que que eu não sei esta
merda aí meu amigo o cara vai aprendendo
com o que dá né Eu aprendi muito com o
filme pornô pornô decora tudo primeira
vez que eu fui nos Estados Unidos a
mulher what's your name eu disse My Oh
yes oh no xingar inglês é outra parada é
Show O cara chega
motherf só que é muita coisa você chega
em muito tempo aqui a gente resolve um
segundo [__] que pariu Pronto né tomar
no cu [__] que pariu mas aí o cara tem
que aprender né o cara tem o Mig agora
por que é tão complicado o egípcio é
mais fácil e o inglês não é o egíto no
egitto o cara fala Eu quero um gato que
que ele faz ele desenha a [__] do gato
é isso aqui é um gato pronto 3 milhões
de anos a gente acha [__] da pedra que
é que tá escrito n Ele tá dizendo aqui
que ele queria um gato Ai não sei que
não sei que o sol como é que ele faz ele
vai lá na pedra e desenha a [__] do Sol
acha 3 milhões de anos que é isso aqui
um sol Ele tá dizendo que amava o sol